legislation
on this
so um
we
that was the focus of additional
legislation
so that's um
i think that's kind of where we left
that and
all of us were in agreement
that that's what we should do on that
bill
is there any
discussion that anyone would like to
have
it's not even in the bill
oh i know but that does it's still
education funding
okay
yeah i i agree is not in the bill but
that
we i think we all agreed that what was
in the bill
was not where we wanted to be
but we did have several over the course
of the year
last year we had several meetings
between um
education
committee and our committee
and that's where we ended up with the
focus
okay sounds good so i guess i need a uh
a motion to
uh
i don't even know what i do to put
forward
for additional legislation
um i'll move the motion that we um
that hb 623 be considered for future
legislation in the next session
okay
any further discussion
okay seeing none
uh will the clerk please call the roll
thank you madam chair
uh representative weiler yes
representative burris yes
representative petrie votes yes
representative emerick
representative perf no
representative edwards yes
representative bean
representative mooney
representative norgren yes
representative bucco
representative leishman is not here
representative hatch is not here
representative heath yes
arizona murray
yes
and representative bumberger yes
madam chair the vote is 16-2 in the
affirmative
represent heath would you mind writing
up a little blurb
oh i can't use the word blurb anymore
but
report
yeah okay thank you thank you very much
this is what she doesn't know
right here uh
probably
thank you
okay
the next bill is um house bill 1300
this is dealing with the ash landfill
they had come in and asked for i believe
five hundred thousand dollars
five yeah five hundred thousand dollars
charge them
on the landfill
and uh for
making sure that
nothing happened to the landfill over
the course of the next 50 years
and of the uh ash landfill is kind of a
unique situation in that it was
taken over by a non-profit
and obviously the non-profit
had
collected money from the towns that had
been using the landfill
so that they could
manage the landfill for some number of
years
25 maybe
and
they had thought that that agreement
which des had approved
20 years ago probably
that that once
this thing ran out once the the the
25 years
program 30 years program whatever it was
anyhow that that would take care of
everything
so
got together and came up with a solution
that was not going to
cost any
additional dollars i believe that the
letter from des was
sent to everyone
and um
as far as i know everybody is happy
so we are not recommending any further
legislation
on this particular bill
so
could i please have a motion
don't all speak at once thank you ken
you're sweet
do i have a second
okay mary
uh represented heath
who was a second
representative heath
hey thank you
did you take mine
no i took here i took yours
okay so
so representative weiler
uh
made the motion representative heath
what was the emotion uh not recommended
for further religiously not recommended
for further legislation okay
keith right no
he's heath
okay
for the clerk to call the roll
commander chair uh representative weiler
yes
represents the brewers yes
representative petri votes yes
representative emrick yes
representative irf yes
representative griffin
representative edwards yes
representative bean yeah
lynn yes representative mooney
yes
representative shercott yes
representative walner
representative norgren
representative buco
representative uh
walsh
representative heath yes representative
murray yes
president of hamburger yes
madam chair of the vote is
to zero in the affirmative
is hb 1665
and this was establishing a municipal
road and bridge disaster relief fund
[Music]
this
all
came about because of the problems they
were having
in the western part of the state
with the last
and there was
a lot of damage to roads and bridges and
so on
however
we did
pass a bill
and the governor signed it
for
the towns
to be able to um
request money from the state to assist
with
disaster
declarations
that had occurred
and uh because of that
action
uh we determined
that um
there would be no
we
we recommended that there would be uh
no further
uh legislative action
uh taken on
um
that's kind of where we left it and we
recognize that um
you know
some towns have been overwhelmed if
that's the right term
with costs and but
we thought that what we had done
legislatively
would help to mitigate the problems
so
division two recommended no further
action and i i would like to make that
motion okay thank
you second
second who said
can i represent turcotte
okay and
seeing none will the clerk call the roll
down commander chair uh representative
wilder
yes
representative burris yes
there's petrie votes yes representative
emerick yes
representative earth yes representative
griffin
verizon edwards yes representative bean
yes
representative lynn yes
arizona mooney
yes representative turcotte yes
representative walner
street's not here no i'm sorry
uh representative norgren yes
virgil bucco
walsh
arizona heath yes
representative murray yes representative
umberger yes
madam chair the vote is
okay thank you
uh is there uh
representative
little blurb
little report this is for
uh ken yeah i gave one to ken oh he's
already gone yeah well we got two yeah
is there any further business to be
brought before us today
okay seeing none
um
i would like to um
just recognize that uh
robert de bears is not running
again
for the house seat from berlin
and so i think that we
need to um
give him a nice round of applause for
everything that he has done
not only in finance but on ways and
means and whatever other committees he
yeah municipal accounting whatever other
committees he served on and
i would
i would like to
personally say
that not only did he serve
spent a lot of time driving back and
forth taking care of his mother
and um and that is uh
that was
something that i know you did because
you wanted to but
we really really thank you for all your
years of service and
i know you're going to miss it
and so we'll look forward to your name
on the ballot in 24.
okay so thank you
[Applause]
would you like gets elected as county
commission
yeah
yes thank you madam chair i mean yeah i
i really have um
i was really troubled for you know by
not running again because i'm worried
about the three reps that'll be
representing berlin
um there's a lot of you know there's no
in you know institutional history and
whatnot
and i i thank you for acknowledging the
fact that i've been going back and forth
and you know after doing that for over
20 years it gets a little bit tiring i
think my vehicle is falling apart
to say the least but i'm going to be
running for county commissioner
unopposed nobody wants to challenge me
having been the delegation chair for
many many years so which is really good
we are faced with a number of problems
in coast county
we are not only the largest county we're
the only county with two nursing homes
the only county with no
interstate highway
uh our our revenues are keeps going
dwindling
so i'm looking at
trying to save us money by doing some
dramatic cuts to some of the departments
so
um i may not be popular but i think it's
time to bite the bullet
okay thank you very very much and
you know in i get really bored as county
commissioner i'll be back
so be forewarned
well thank you thank you very much thank
you robert uh is there anyone else that
has any grand news
okay
i said 15 minutes
20 minutes i'm sorry we got carried away
thank you adjourned
no
consent can all this
oh yeah i don't think
you